remember when Bears fans blame Cody
Parky for the double dink what if I told
you it technically wasn't his fault
let's take you back to 2019 the Bears s
to a 12 and4 record and had their top
five defense and they were in a slugfest
at home against the Eagles in the Wild
Card round and what happened next shaped
the Bears future Cody had a chance to
win it for the bears but here's the
thing he wasn't having a good season
that year he missed 10 kicks That season
and you won't believe that he hit the
uprights five times for which all
happened in one game so of course the
biggest kick of his career ended the
same way it DED off the upright not once
but twice but what most people didn't
know was that the misfield goal attempt
was technically not his fault the NFL
ruled a block on the play if you look
closely it definitely was tipped by a
Defender but obviously all Bears fans
saw was another miss kick by Cody maybe
that kick is the reason why the Bears
haven't had a winning season since but
make no mistake about it it wasn't all
on Cody for that one